[Applaudissements]
alors y en a un que je voudrais pas
parce qu'il est capable de répliquer
c'est jean luc lemoine
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue dans tout ce pas un mot très
facile de faire ce métier comme vous
pouvez le constater alors qu'est ce que
vous avez à nous raconter des amis
jean-luc bas je suis très heureux et
puis je trouve que vous vous embellir et
très bien c'est magnifique on applaudit
ou petite beauté alors l'arrêtent
on n'arrête pas les très sérieux parce
qu'ici a appris qu'après va s'énerver
après qu'est-ce que j'ai affalé là non
je m'en excuse moi tu mimiques la cua a
bien limité et une limite à jeter oui je
te mérite pas on ne devait pas être là
laurent blanc lui
[Rires]
on avait dit que tu serais pas là donc
je m'étais dit ça c'était une
opportunité de serra si une opportunité
donc ça ça me dérange pas mais on
l'avait dit tu faisais toi là tu en
train de muter que je mérite moi ça
s'annule
oui tu imites mal chum et moi moi moi je
suis mythomane huawei thumy mythe mal
j'ai un prix d'interprétation à cannes
je tu es très très bien jean luc gillme
et bien on pas vu le jour bien pression
à huit bras
[Applaudissements]